Alyssa Milano is back to host the new
season of Project Runway all-stars
et chatted with the busy mom of two
about dressing for her body and what
makes her feel most fulfilled your body
has gone through the changes of being
pregnant and then losing the weight what
have you learned about dressing for your
body as it goes through those changes I
think dressing you know for proportion
is really really really important so if
you're a little wider mm-hmm you know
you have to pick a lengths that work
with your width you have to feel good on
the inside to look good on the outside
so you know I try to make a very
purposeful decision to not really worry
about wheat fluctuations or changes and
just wear what makes me feel good do you
feel your most confident right now in
your life than you or a hundred percent
yeah so much more confident now than I
went in my 20 and I think a lot of that
has to do in motherhood because I
realized my purpose and I know that
sounds so sort of cliche but when the
first time I hold my low I was like oh
this is it this is what life is my life
really began even though I had a very
full beautiful life before him my life
really began when eight the day he was
born
you